[Music]
one hallmark of moral outrage is
expressing it feels so good and brain
imaging studies have shown that when we
punish bad behavior you see activation
in the striatum which is a brain area
that we know to be involved in signaling
rewards it's receiving input inputs from
the dopamine system one of the strands
of research that I've done over the past
several years is looking at how brain
chemicals like serotonin regulate our
desire to punish bad behavior and so
we've done studies where we bring people
into the lab and we manipulate their
serotonin levels drive them down or
drive them up temporarily I look to see
how likely people are to punish unfair
behavior and and what are the brain
correlates of those decisions and one
thing that we found repeatedly is that
when we temporarily lower serotonin this
makes people more likely to punish
unfair behavior and what we see in the
brain concurrently is that the striatum
is more active when people are punishing
so by changing the levels of this
neurotransmitter we can actually change
the motivational value of punishment
this is interesting because serotonin is
a neurotransmitter whose raw ingredient
you can only get from your diet so the
building block of serotonin is
tryptophan tryptophan is an essential
amino acid which means you can only
intake tryptophan by eating enough
proteins so this means that this
neurotransmitter system may be very
finely attuned to the relative abundance
or scarcity of resources in the
environment it may be the case that when
resources are relatively scarce this
could affect serotonin levels which then
could sensitize people to unfairness
lack of cooperation and make them more
likely to punish and
proximate mechanism for that is it makes
the act of punishment perhaps more
valuable or rewarding the ultimatum game
is a situation where two people have to
agree on how to split the sum of money
or some other resource or neither person
gets any money so it's a two-step game
in the first step the proposer gets the
resource and makes a proposal to the
responder the second person about how to
divide that up so it could be let's say
$20 and the proposer makes an offer to
the responder of say five dollars out of
the 20 the responder then has the option
of accepting that offer in which case
both players are paid those amounts or
they can reject the offer in which case
neither player gets any money so they
can essentially destroy the whole pie if
they're unsatisfied with the offer
hundreds and hundreds of studies have
been run with ultimatum games when it
was first published in the eighties
economists were very surprised that the
average person was very likely to reject
any offer that fell below around 30%
from a rational choice perspective that
takes only money outcomes into account
this is irrational in the sense that
some money is better than no money so
why would you reject any nonzero offer
in the game but of course the the beauty
of this game is that it demonstrates
very powerfully that people care about a
whole lot more than just money they care
about being respected about fairness and
they really dislike being in a situation
of disadvantageous inequality so for
someone who's offered a very small
portion of the total pie it's worth it
to them to forego that small amount in
order to say screw you to the other
person the ultimatum game is
I think relevant for a lot of the
political events that we've seen over
the past few years because economic
arguments have not seemed to work this
was one of the big failures of the
remain campaign and brexit they
continually argued and and tried to
persuade that the the economic costs of
brexit would be grave and of course
they're correct on that but what we know
from the ultimatum game is that when
faced with a choice between accepting a
little bit of money versus expressing
one's identity expressing one's
dissatisfaction with the current
situation a lot of people will prefer
the expressive behavior even if it comes
at an economic cost and so one put one
possible explanation for why that
argument was so ineffective is because
again people care a lot more about their
identities and their communities then
simply economics we are living in a time
of dramatic economic inequality where
the top 1% or however you want to carve
it up has captured the lion's share of
economic gains over the past several
decades and people on the losing end of
this deal are pissed off about it this
is very unfair and so I think what we're
seeing all around the world with the
rise of populism is a kind of global
large-scale society level version of an
ultimatum game where the offer that has
been dealt to those in the bottom half
of the economic ladder are unsatisfied
and expressing that dissatisfaction with
their votes and this is a wake up call
that this level of inequality really is
not
thing of all
[Music]